it's fun I enjoy I enjoy talking [ __ ] to
the audience I love people telling me
what I cannot do because I'm gonna do it
10 times over it's like my dream to be
like somehow in a ring at a pay-per-view
yeah in some way in my life I'll get
[ __ ] if I get famous enough where I
could just go out there and get [ __ ]
up like they pull really you want to do
that I'll be like front row and I get
pulled over and I gotta take a bump or
get thrown down the table really please
oh my gosh you sound like me I can't
wait to bleed for the first time to have
like a street fight and like the shot of
the blood just go oozing through my face
and my hair and like I don't know what
I'm doing I have to get a new wig when I
go to the airport but yeah I know I
can't wait I'm yeah and AWS they've had
some bloody moments so far plenty yeah
plenty so whenever I have my first
street fight I mean if I allow them to
even touch me then I can't wait because
I'm gonna like just
I'm excited that sounds wild though but
that sounds just as wild as you saying
you want to go through a table yeah put
me I would love to get put through a
table but like even if it's by like uh
you know like a master job or like Dolph
Ziggler or somebody you know
you want to go through a table
regardless yeah all right yeah all right
let's maybe let's go through a table one
day yeah maybe if I can't touch them
oh my God
greatest rapper of all who who what's
his real name I don't know Shad Moss
team Moss bruh I don't even know what
happened okay okay so help me yeah so
this Bow Wow thing right yeah how much
of the Bow Wow thing was like storyline
like uh he's obviously a very small guy
very he's kind of small and round now
the 30s have hit it just like they hit
me he didn't look that I mean he he
doesn't look round at all I think he
just you know feels out in the face a
little but other than that do why now
too yeah it's a trick but yeah so so
obviously the the bow I think was
overshade it was like everywhere yeah
like how much of that was like uh
because break down the Bow Wow storyline
and was it like mostly some storyline
[ __ ] on TV or you know like like what
happened
I don't know what happened with it yeah
um something was supposed to happen it
didn't happen and we moved on from the
situation did you ever listen to him
growing up I did I think everybody did
but I was more of a Romeo fan really I
was more of a Romeo fan I like bow wow
they both kind of ran 106 in park as a
kid I watched kind of but I played
basketball so I was out like at practice
when that came on when did that come on
like seven something like that seven
yeah yeah